[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en janvier 1998 l'impossible est arrivé
[Musique]
on s'était pourtant préparée mais pas
assez un million et demi d'abonnés se
retrouve dans le noir c'est ce que vous
aviez je renouvelle mon soir une bonne
nouvelle malheureusement non non non non
en fait le pire est à venir et on l'a
peint surtout cette nuit du coup c'est
un gros bruit je regarde par la fenêtre
je vois justement le poteau en train de
le pylône après un plus haut de la pile
tous de suivre jusqu'au cinquième rang
tandis qu'une image vaut mille mots
alors regardez bien ce que vous voyez là
c'est le centre-ville de montréal plongé
dans le noir vivons aujourd'hui la
période je dirais la journée la plus
critique de tout ce qui peut être fait
pour un sortie avec le maintenant fait
que nous pouvons maintenant avoir des
espérances du poteau constamment et un
style rouge ses sabots ça sans
électricité réseaux monsieur et madame
mandroux allait l'hydro-québec arrêter
de penser qu'on va l'électricité dans
ses jours ici je dis et je le répète ça
ressemble à la bosnie vous faudrait
d'autres général
oui c'est un appel que je lance
immédiatement tous les québécois à
toutes les québécoises affichent ont
pourvu de l'électricité de communiquer
avec leurs parents leurs amis qui sont
dans la difficulté de les inviter à même
de les convaincre à venir de me répéter
cain d'image que de souvenirs ceux qui
l'ont vécue s'en souviendront
probablement toute leur vie on a entendu
la détresse chez les agriculteurs mais
tous ceux qui ont été privés
d'électricité pendant dix semaines
on ne pouvait pas imaginer qu'une chose
pareille puisse se produire au québec
la crise du verglas de 98 a marqué à
jamais l'histoire du québec et pour
souligner cet anniversaire de cette
catastrophe naturelle la plus importante
du temps vraiment au canada nous vous
présentons ce soir cette édition
spéciale de 24,60 du 5 au 9 janvier 98
jusqu'à 100 millimètres de pluie
verglaçante temps sur le sud du québec
les installations d'hydro-québec ne
résiste pas à l'accumulation de verglas
les pylônes et les poteaux c'est
fendront crois pas que ça puisse arriver
est donc un million de personnes dans le
noir du centre du québec jusqu'à
l'outaouais et lors de ce fameux
vendredi mois dont on va vous parler au
plus fort de la crise ce sont trois
millions et demi de québécois qui sont
sans électricité
c'est la moitié de la population si
lucien bouchard qui dirige le québec à
ce moment là vingt ans plus tard
l'ancien premier ministre nous emmène
dans les coulisses de cette crise du
verglas qui a très certainement marqué
son mandat de premier ministre en soit
monsieur bouchard vous regardez ces
images avec une certaine émotion je
pense à 20 ans plus tard peut-être ne
les aviez vous prévu depuis qu'est ce
que vous ressentez à les revoir
qu'est ce que c'est
menés en ce moment de gravité je suis
beaucoup d'inquiétude mais de gravité
qui était évidemment associé à
l'obligation où on se trouve alors je me
trouvais de la tête du combat mais d'un
conte voir un certain vide à pauillac et
on n'avait pas prévu qu'une chose comme
ça arriverait
il y avait pas de plein de chic rite
égalité de lâcher c'était une hypothèse
est absolument invraisemblable alors du
tout imaginé tout improvisé
en fait on travaille à l'instinct puis
moi personnellement je me suis retrouvé
là demain avec le sentiment qu'il
fallait trouver la famille ont tranché
celle d'une famille bien mûres a des
preuves qui nous menacent qu'est ce
qu'on fait
mon côté je vais la femme et la réunir
d'abord l'assuré on a réuni bien espérer
un minimum de confiance différents sorte
qu'on puisse ensemble trouver des
solutions pour durer et traverser
survivent et même si possible le dossier
la situation alors on n'a rien vu comme
ça dans ce sens que j'étais arrivé un
peu une façon insidieuse dans le
déclenchement de cette crise je me
souviens que j'arrivais de québec on
peut être quelque part aux environs du
sien granville 400 granville
enfin peut-être et déjà il y avait une
mauvaise température jeu
et puis on rentre en auto je pense qu'il
est que l'avion ne volait pas en vantant
le tout payant est entré avec une
voiture du gouvernement y avait des
gardes du corps avec moi et on avait
emprunté la 40
là il n'en sur la rive nord mais là de
plus en plus les conditions étaient chez
détériorer l'accumulation de glace de
neige ont bloqué et en arrivant à
trois-rivières les gardes du corps ont
décidé de bifurquer par l'a20 alors
emprunter le pont de trois rivières puis
en italie sur l'a20 j'ai pas tellement
mieux
puis on est rentré à montréal il a
évidemment en arrivant à montréal
n'était pas quelque chose et si le
lendemain que l'ampleur d'accueil de
nuit est tombée dessus immédiate malades
dont vous êtes vous deviez partir en
mission oui on est prêt à partir dans la
rue amérique latine avec une mission
économique présidée à l'époque monsieur
jean entretien avec tous les mobiles des
jeux du canada
mais évidemment les parties fallait
rester parce que dès le lundi le mardi
on peut pas on l'appréhendé pas une
aggravation nécessairement annoncé ce
matin entre pascal yiacouvakis le pire
est à venir
le premier ministre se transforme en bon
père de famille et en perdra mais qui
dit faux pense à la sécurité il doit
vous découvrez vous vous êtes le chef
d'un gouvernement et vous découvrir
qu'on n'a pas de plantes
on n'a pas de plan d'urgence que ce qui
était ce qui apparaissait invincible du
côté d'hydro-québec
les pilotes ont même les ingénieurs les
gens talk élections sont un ingrédient
sont tellement de retours se font
dépasser les 100 du dessus ouais alors
on est en hiver c'est froid oui mais
tout de suite
évidemment char lire un sentiment tout à
fait
normal et cherche pas je retourne à mon
bureau oui ça devient une seconde went
wrong l'insolent déclic mon bureau je
passais la et très rapidement par la
force des choses il n'y a pas eu de
comité de réflexion on a peur des choses
on a déconnecté toutes les agences
gouvernementales pour les amener vers
moi tout est centralisé les mondiaux
qu'est ce qui vous faisait dire que
c'était comme premier ministre que vous
deviez agir ils n'ont pas laissé seul à
la sécurité publique aux municipalités
vous allez constater tout de suite que
l'ampleur du québec québec et noir de la
famille il faut les poches du super g
avec une agence un compte chez un comité
même ministère
parce que même le ministère lui-même
avait pas avait pas de plan proposé
sacha treille aurélien personnes qui le
lui reprocher non plus sa chaleur en
chine naturellement je remets ça s'est
fait naturellement retrouvé autour
autour de jugement une cellule à mon
bureau à l'hydro québec l'ancien bureau
du premier ministre du québec puisque la
haye et c'est quand même un hasard quand
même rue à la suite quand je trouve à
100 vous aider je sais prendre mes
chevaux l'ascension des esclaves à quel
moment ça s'est imposée parce que c'est
aussi ce que l'on retient cette
politique de communication vous avez dit
xala pour rassembler pour rassurer
ouais parler aux québécois mais chaouchi
chantier fait naturellement dès les
premières journées d'aller vraiment
journée on avait fini les gens autour de
moi là
on trouve évidemment le
président-directeur général de vie
drôles cas ils les chefs de police divin
qui avait qui s'occupait de
communication s'occuper d'accueillir
s'occuper qui avaient des services
publics en général certains chefs
politiques et puis surtout on surtout
autour de 1 mondiaux au début on était
peut-être indigènes puis avait
finalement été peut-être 25 et la city
est devenu très rapidement formalisé
c'est à dire que tous les matins
retraite ou 7h 8h tout le monde se
retrouve autour de mon bureau on faisait
le point ont passé des commandes
et puis tout de suite on a joué mais on
parle du comment mais la population a vu
j'avance je parte il faut l'informer
alors en fin d'après-midi les vins
qu'ils avaient reçu des missions nouera
des cons il souvent il le faisait en
temps réel à la télévision parce
qu'andré caillé et moi on se présentait
dans un studio qui a été improvisée dans
une chaire des conférences des idées au
québec depuis lors d'une conférence de
presse qui n'était pas très préparée il
n'y avait pas de communiquer ya pas de
communicateur qui fit si la détecte on
n'a pas le temps toute façon et la vie
moi très naturellement compte si on
avait été dans l'intimité
on racontait aux québécois je prendrais
fait durant la journée comment je
présentais la crise qui a asséché
améliorer n'ont jamais dire être payante
quand j'ai les moyens qu'on prenait pour
faisait venir des gens qui avaient aussi
des missions et vous verrez une penderie
des commandes et des couvertures
on avez vous trouvé h et non comme un
poteau d'acier mais qu est-ce qu
pourquoi ligne raconté pourquoi
mais demain on va être capital à
l'évincer les besoins vitaux qui fait
l'air encore plus grande préoccupation
c'était quoi ce moment-là agite la vie
personne dans les maisons sécurité
physique était très très menacé
ya t il ya eu cette fameuse nuit du
vendredi noir du vendredi noir où il n'y
avait plus qu'une ligne d'électricité
pour alimenter montréal
cette ligne de chant mégawatts serait
tombée plus rien à montréal aurait fallu
évacuer montréal mais bakou et comment
tous les projets bloqués ont regardé une
fois tous suivent les bouées ce vendredi
noir est assez évocatrice parce que ce
seront des images on ne voyait plus rien
à montréal et c'est le moment
vous deviez faire quoi ce moment ont
invité la paix ni informer les gens
ouais mais jusqu'où informer les
machines en question n'est pas tout dit
il est d'abord question du rouge à
écouter chaque nuit j'ai acheté un film
île battue par des vents violents et les
fils comment je l'aï ballotte mais il y
avait mouvement d'agitation
j'étais déprimé profil et là le fils
exercice sur les touches d'un côté à
l'autre du fleuve à l'eau du fleuve
dépression est telle qu'il ya eu 27
tombes et je suis tombé là il y avait
peu de puits d'eau n'avaient plus rien à
montréal est est ce que c'est vrai qu'à
ce moment là j'en opposé le soir même il
fallait poser parce que ça allons livrer
donné quoi de durer parce qu'elle est au
fond si les gens paniquaient quitté
montréal les ponts étaient bloqués de
toute façon il y avait sûrement que le
tunnel parut de pantin
et au fond est ce que c'est vrai qu'on a
progressé de provoquer une panne plus
grande à montréal pour détourner
l'électricité
dutil on a besoin de d'apporter sur
l'île l'énergie produite par beauharnois
il y avait un gros problème c'est que la
grosse ligne détention kit de là et
avait été bloqué parce que il ya un fil
de garde mais si je continue comme ça
qu'on appelle choix quitte à tomber chez
les conducteurs et c'était non partout
des choses il fallait l'établi enlever
les fils dégâts si la laque et hydro
québec a demandé à deux de ses employés
de monter à bord d'un hélicoptère dans
des vents très violents
là d'où ce tour-là était énorme à une
hauteur de plusieurs centaines de villes
journal
ils sont montés dans l'hélicoptère il
faut s'accrocher après l'écouté
d'hélicoptères je vous avertis sud
la touriste est tombé sur l'atout pour
aller débranchez le film je vais leur
vie s'il est clairement des vrais heures
de fou un affaire de fous mais ça a
marché
alors s'il est rétabli le courant de
cheikh thiam heliowatt de plus qui sont
rentrés sur l'île l'acea a permis de
maintenir en fonctionnement les hôpitaux
les généralistes mais je parle parce que
c'est ce que tout était affecté les
résidences pour personnes à dix
agriculteurs les résidences pour
personnes âgées les hôpitaux
non je voudrais puits d'eau potable est
extrêmement tellement inquiétant de 7,6
jour là quel est le souvenir ne plus
j'oserais dire le plus angoissant le
plus inquiétant ou le plus beau du
souvenir si en hausse on peut dire que
des bouts soudan la somalie
je pense
la fameuse nuit là c'était très
angoissant parce que on se rapproche
confrères lendemain c'est l'inconnu sa
poche qu'on ressent quand est ce qu'elle
n'a pas dit que ce serait installé et
pas d'eau pas de déguster pas de
chauffage pas pouvoir sortir de la ville
sinon que à travers le goulot
d'étranglement qui était un tunnel des
conditions extrêmement difficiles
là ça aurait été vraiment peiné il
faudrait pas que ça arrive en fait il
fallait pas il faudrait pas que charles
élections voilà pourquoi c'est pas
arrivé finalement de changer le fait la
tenue mais si vous savez au bon moment
il y en a eu plusieurs cas les moments
de solidarité
j'étais absolument remarquables a marqué
un but jean de braye a pas eu de panique
l'évasion est très sérieux puis gens
très très content tout à fait compris
qu' il fallait se donner la main l'appui
qu'il fallait suivre des consignes et
qu'il fallait être prudent et puis on
emmenait des corrections à la télévision
andré caillé banon soutient guy cayer sa
folie c'est d'abord un homme des chiens
docteur en sciences physiques mais c'est
surtout un administrateur avait un
communicateur avoir passé ce qui est
avéré
je me souviens du jour où on était
justement en train de faire une
conférence de presse puis quelqu'un
appelle puis il crachait lama génie
génératrice mais il faut que je
débranche pour une halte à abidjan
écoutez monsieur je vous dis qu'on va
faire là où elle est génératrice elle
était en bandages
dans le choc très bien des chalets d'un
sous sol où un panneau électrique la wii
t'approcher vous tire là vous voyez là
et ammann est là et puis la manette
il ya deux positions il ya envoyé là bas
mais tu vas tout le monde l'a compris
moi la langue ou alors il ya eu des
moments comme ça oui je crois qu'on
tient musée mais ici bouchard moment
faire cet entretien je peux pas m'en
empêcher d'aborder la question la
catalogne parce que les résultats entre
et se dégagerait une majorité pour les
trois partis indépendantistes
je fais le lien avec rené lévesque avait
souligné le 30e anniversaire de son
décès à l'automne que vous disiez une
phrase que vous êtes tout se passe comme
si rené lévesque avait emporté avec lui
la ferveur qui anime et le québec et son
époque ce site au québec le québec a
changé en 20 ans depuis ce fameux se
trouve sourire de l'âme mais quand vous
regardez à distance la catalogne est ce
que pour vous c'est un peuple déterminé
résilient qu'est ce que c'est
qu'est-ce que ça évoque pour vous voilà
voilà dans l'histoire sont reconnus dans
un très grand peuple opprimé connais mes
pieds long interview de l'espagne puis
chante atouts économiques et chercheur
économique pour l'espagne mais oui
manifestement j'étais un peuple
brésilien qui est et qui garde le fil de
ses idées mais en même temps je trouve
ça j'éprouve un sentiment assez
s'il perplexe j'avais ce qui se passe là
bas parce que j'ai pas envie de voir la
violence
j'ai pas aimé puis je pense pas qu'il
était très très bien gérée d'un côté
comme de l'autre à surveiller mais bon
je pense avec lui
chances de la responsabilité
démocratique qui je pense pas qu'on
arrive à engager québécois dans une
entreprise qui avait pas de majorité
suffisante quand même temps vous voyez
que ils voudront plus est par ailleurs
j'espère que non plus mais je voyais
aussi qu'on peut faire des comparaisons
entre j'ai passé là bas la façon dont
les choses se passent d'abord comme on
le fait ici j'ai envie que en 1995 il a
pas moins 95 % des québécois quant à
l'essai jeux primés ou je te bute un
titre extrêmement intense il faut
l'avoir vécu ce que c'était pas eu un
seul incident violent j'en ai pas vu la
police nulle part oui oui oui là quand
je trouve que chez nous on en change la
démocratie aussi bien au niveau du
canada anglais que du québec qui peut
nous enorgueillir une grande cuillère
parce que si constitionnel ici avec
l'édition d'abord les tribunes ont été
mis à contribution pour prendre de
partir d'argile compliqué là mais on
n'est pas du seul zoo
j'ai autant on aperçoit dans la règle de
droit puis d'un je pense qu'il va y
avoir des anicroches ps un seul match a
été absolument remarquable et on a
montré qu'on était à une vraie
démocratie au québec et au canada
voilà on veut démontrer on peut voir
aujourd'hui maintenant quatre ans qu'on
parle je parle d'abord par approche qui
chaouchi parce que c'est digitimes une
démarche comme celle des huitièmes il
faut choix réaliste ou 6 1 ne serait pas
plus loin
merci merci